men are suffering they have different
problems than women have but they don't
have it better they need our sympathy
they need our love and they need each
other more than anything else they need
to be together do you think women
understand what it's like to be a man
not at all no clue no idea did you like
being a woman before Ned I did but I
like it more now cuz I think it's more
of a privilege being a man is much yeah
it's really true it's so funny because
the women will say that I hate women
because I point out the realities of how
privileged of lives we have they hate me
for it I mean I think I get more hate
than really I get hate from the left and
the right